[Music]
youtube
top rank now come on we're not we're not
doing this anymore
stop it stop it stop it i've gotten
enough trouble
i've got enough videos removed unless i
oh wait what is the joke exactly
oh okay okay it's fine
okay i got it never mind you're okay all
right i thought you were doing something
like sony entertainment television like
no i can't no
whoa what is this dr phil reach out to
you
so my team and i figured this was the
best way oh
we're kind of strangers no host main
review you already
goes against the rules we know but i'm
willing to make a full commitment to it
you wouldn't get this offer from any
other guy
oh i hope you're feeling the same way so
you can understand
i'm never gonna no no
no ah
you're dead to me dr phil how could you
oh i fell for it burrito you sly
dog you demon of the night
always making me suffer no
we barely just started the video fine
one strike that's all i'm getting do i
dare to click on this okay we're fine
next me when your landlord says no dogs
it looks like edgar
what is that ramen noodles
it's not a dog it's ramen noodle trust
me it's delicious
girls with blonde hair can never be
interesting girls with color hair
are generally not epic but girls with
brown hair
the best yeah dude i look like it's such
a baby when i shave what is this
hey baby pewds back in the house
it's been two years felix you should
google yourself now it's time
my time has come i'm actually curious i
kind of want to do it now
what have we got apparently i've googled
myself to click on my youtube channel
good job felix
alright video coming up wait and see
and oh it's going to be great oh it's
going to be fantastic
makes me kind of sad that it's been two
years since i've been in japan
and uh it breaks my soul it hurts it
pewdiepie how ai thinks pewds look
without a beard yeah
well here you go this is what i actually
look like a goddamn baby
like a little child not like an american
how ai thinks beerus
this looks with a beard wow good job ai
you did it thanks for that neck i
appreciate that's a thick neck god
damn god damn
i told her wendy williams i can't
believe it she denies farting on air
she's lying about it like this because
it's comfortable
you know no no no one sits like this
because it's comfortable
she farted she ripped the fat one admit
it at least had the balls to admit it
wendy i mean you're lucky you only got
battery
it's like bass boost i mean
you're lucky you only got battery i was
surprised there wasn't no [ __ ]
the four horsemen of outros that was it
guys subscribe to become a pro brofist
what look at graph for every new
subscriber
i get a new subscriber do you think it's
working
i'm curious i need to check my analytics
i never go there anymore
whoa it's totally working every
subscriber i get a new subscriber guys
come on
mr b's 50 milliwatt looks almost better
than pewds damn
congrats mr peace is that like on top of
a 10 million one
sick love isn't real explain this
yeah explain this scientist you can't
oh she was blonde for the wedding
oh my god i'm dead guys this is before
the lockdown thank god we had the
wedding before the lockdown
sheesh oh my god i would i would be so
annoyed
this is how the swiss kennel was cleared
this is such good memes i didn't cover
any of this but it's so
[Music]
funny
get him get him yes
they had to call me and that's why i
didn't upload for two days
it had to be done that's sick ryan
bigness
how big your nose though i want to know
it was a pleasure to meet you
come on i'll take you home okay babe
[Laughter]
get out of here he ain't got no legs
i laugh at a family guy sketch that's
amazing thank you
behold kitty the infinite automatic
smart artist sorting artist voicing auto
smeltery nader
that's so cute i'm just collecting sand
to melt it in my
infinite automatic smart automatic this
money got max meltinator because i built
it i need to do something with it
one day i'll find that lime sauce you
will never find me gordon
you will never find me
that's my cover of the death note theme
i don't know you tell me how i did
i'm cutting your pp me who is already
circumcised
too late 20 years too late
[Music]
don't threaten me you don't want to know
what a double circumcision looks like
four hours of intros what is this hey
how's it going bros my name is
yes
2021 is the dark ages he should have
called his automatic sorting system
ass no
how did i not see this we were so close
to greatness
well actually it's an infinite automatic
smarter it means
his automatic system felix 19 year olds
it's so automated it's insane bro it
doesn't just automate all the items it
also smells this
items automatically that needs to be
automated and it's automatic did i
mention
it's automatic system i tend to
automatically say it too many times
martza finally did it she find out how
to bring them to life no
no god damn it
sit this is a cry for help help me
call in the jiu jitsu sorcerers i need
help
there needs to be a cleanse first scene
footage of pewdiepie felix shelby
marzia's husband
uh collaborating together that's so
wholesome that's so nice
after all why not why shouldn't i
balance the switch
that's sick what happens it must like
charge up infinitely and then that's too
much power i couldn't
i couldn't fathom what to do with it hey
felix can you tell ken that i liked his
shirt
sure i will tell them
mobile game man the game i feel like
i've seen this
level one crook level 100 mafia boss
there it is
download tuber simulator guys her he's
probably thinking about educate
he if two of my memes get into a single
video lawyer will i get two peepees
or one extra large peepee dude i'll take
two peepees any day
double peepee oh my god that's ppp
yo me and might start playing you put
your tetras
and then there's one [ __ ] character
that goes
it's so annoying
someone did the voice acting for that
it's so tough what is this is someone
explained to me why
cute has a watch for each wrist it's
funny how you guys
make fun of me and you can't tell the
difference between a bracelet and a
goddamn watch
pewdiepie is so dumb he doesn't
understand is that a watch
it dumb yellow dumb small penis
hey guys it's me felix shelberg how dare
you
hey why is everyone hating on me
everyone loves the friendly neighbor guy
felix cagelberg come on
you like me come on [ __ ] pewdiepie he's
dead
if he's so good why he dead huh he died
pewdiepie died
march 23rd what can i say i died at the
suzuka international racing course guys
it's on the internet
okay what happened i was on my way to
london to meet several other youtubers
uh and i lost control of his vehicle on
the m23
that's impossible i drive a volvo oh
down the crawley
dude i get so mad i know this is not
appropriate but like
stop crashing your cars please there's
always a goddamn accident on the m23
bra which i know is bad but it's
inconveniencing me
so just stop okay can we stop having
traffic accidents
hello trying to drive here hello
killing me instantly sh i was hoping i
at least get like an anime speech like
blood
running down my mouth and go you must
carry on
but like i said listen young child
there's no time to explain
take this sword you must continue on the
youtube videos
someone needs to react to reddit content
you know what i mean how is this
possible that
your youtube algorithm took it as fact
that i died on march
23rd like what the [ __ ] my mom asked me
why i was watching two
adult men wearing cat ears your mom
should have been asking why not
i mean wait what
[Music]
oh has that been down this whole time
so embarrassing cringing is it cuter
like this
or like this top comment when's the
lamborghini come on guys
pewdiepie who has a car in high school
90 of american yeah
shut up america you're killing the earth
not me
apologize apologize
apologize
[Music]
oh it broke oh we're back
we're back it's all good
telling my mom i love her in person
telling my mom i love her through text
telling my mom i love her over a call
telling my mom i love her through the y
i love you mom creepers scare me
creeper scares me mom you're child loves
you very deeply
and they wanted me to personally deliver
this message
i don't know the joke was that i was
gonna murder you and i don't know what
was funny about that
i'm a violent person hey that's cute
yeah
i like it spacing it very nice petition
to change hey i like them
that's cool petition granted reddit mods
do your thing
how felix treats marcy after spending an
entire day in minecraft
this is so true i'm a shrimp god damn it
no
[Laughter]
it's too real no it's not funny
[Music]
yes make me my nutella sandwich
ah he's too slow what a noob get out of
here that's some
level one symphory right there
[ __ ] you i got two strikes god damn it i
meet someone
we talk i tell them about my automatic
sorting system they leave
i meet some the cycle of life
really guys by the way have i have i
showed you my automatic minecraft system
so here's my automatic system if i want
to sort items and you can put them in
here
they go through uh they're black you
can't really see them
and then they go in the hole they go
where they need to go
there it is yeah it's working of course
i never doubted it for a second
oh that's so cute
true true match made in heaven
pewdiepie ai pewdiepie i want to talk to
the manager oh
no get that [ __ ] away from me
thank you no but thank you at all
[ __ ] that hell yeah
so i should do
almost cut myself all right next meme
guys
it's training for the anime love it love
it
all right next meme the divorce flipbook
this is a this is a i got it i know what
it is i'm gonna pause it right before
yeah each each i'm done
two strikes that's all you're gonna get
after three years
i have them uh just buy an iphone bro
do you all remember when pewdiepie and
felix shelby made videos together
it's a shame pewdiepie died rest is so
i took over this enterprise someone's
got to do it hello everyone
my name is ej i'm ready this is
my third time trying to get into oh okay
okay
i actually almost gave up
[Laughter]
i'm i'm cautious i'm
never gonna give up okay okay okay we're
fine we're fine
okay
i i actually thought of giving up
but never gonna give up giving up that's
that's
[Music]
so cute
i today's your moment man
you got it man hand-drawn baby
oh the meatball oh so tasty
[Music]
hey
sick
[Music]
that's cool i love this stuff
it's amazing villager no it isn't okay
good
there yeah
[Music]
oh cool whoa it's so wide
hey terraria that's sick
whoa it's so big it's huge whoa
that's so cool
[Music]
yo more up bugs come on
come on
[Music]
huge pp as you can tell oh my god
shout out to oh my god like jesus
got him i saw it i saw it before it it
happened
small pippy look i already small peep at
it that's how fast i am
but you didn't even see my sword getting
unseen that's and cut in half [ __ ] you
two strikes that's all you're getting
your crush her dad
her brother her first love her god damn
it
stop doing this to me stop it ethnicity
estimate
fifty percent swedish peer depay is me
pewdiepie how's it going bros
i am a swedish person and i like uh
meatballs and ikea and abba
it's that all we have exported from
sweden god damn it we're useless
name your child after a fictional
character hey there khaleesi
how was your school hey naming your
child after your favorite automatic
sorting system
i'm so proud of your giga automatic stop
starting myself automatic self infinite
system
i love you dude that's wholesome
parenting
done right dad win that win
that face when you realize these two
are one room yep it's one of the same
baby
which was your favorite i like when
pewdiepie jumped out of closet and went
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna end it there because
i only got two strikes
sookie i will give you up always
always thanks for watching this video
another sub is another sub so sub
now click it
see you guys next time bye caught you
you're using internet without a vpn
cringe oh look at this dude sign up with
nordvpn today
and stop being crazy for those who don't
know a vpn it helps you browse the
internet
safely but most importantly freely get
past annoying country restrictions
i can definitely say that so many times
you try and watch a show and it's like
ah
can't watch it there i got you every
time it's like yeah no problem there's
no bpm i already have the subscription
it's all done i don't have to think
about it it's one of those things that's
really just
it's just good to have i recommend it if
you sign up for a two-year plan with
nordvpn
you get a huge discount plus a one month
additional for free so if you take that
offer it's really good
you sign up using the code pewdiepie
that's how you get epic access to it
you're welcome if that wasn't good
enough for you
and you're not sure if a vpn is really
worth it or not for you
you can try it risk free for 30 days
with a money back guarantee nordvpn
doesn't compromise on speed it's super
fast i use it all the time i can't tell
the difference if i'm using it or not
there's absolutely no data logging
whatsoever
so be safe out there gamers use nordvpn
i recommend it that's nordvpn.com
pewdiepie link in description thank you
for sponsoring this video